Привет! Это шестой урок модуля. В прошлом мы собрали дизайн-систему, самую ее базу, перемены с двумя коллекциями, фундамент-секцию, семь базовых компонентов и контракт в контракт МД.
Этот файлик нам говорит, вернее нашему агенту, о том, что если нет компонента, сначала заводишь его в дизайн-системе, потом используешь на экране и вносишь в общую базу внутри среды.
Сегодня первое применение этого правила, посмотрим, как это работает. У нас уже есть самая база, теперь нужно расширить нашу компонентную базу под наши задачи, под нашу специфику.
У нас уже есть Warframe, есть понимание того, что должно быть, поэтому расширяем UIKit для того, чтобы он покрывал типовые экраны.
На входе у нас то, что уже лежит после урока предыдущего, стартовые компоненты или каталог после сканирования, а на выходе расширенный набор на той же дизайн-системе,
без параллельных копий, без каких-то прибитых цветов и так далее.
Делаем мы это, как обычно, через директиву и давай разберемся, из чего она состоит.
Директива называется Grow UIKit, она состоит из пяти фаз.
Пройдемся по ним и сразу разберем, почему именно так это все дело работает.
Первое это Read.
Агент читает текущий компонент с AMD через ReadTool, держит каталог в контексте на этом сеансе.
Почему так?
Без чтения каталога агент дублирует то, что у тебя уже есть.
Мы уже это обсуждали, он должен держать в голове всю структуру нашей дизайн-системы.
Благодаря тому, что она компактно в текстовом виде описана, этот проблем не составит.
И не забываем, что чтобы у него были актуальные данные, мы ему сообщаем о том, что у нас добавились новые компоненты, у нас что-то изменилось.
Он сам видит твои изменения, если не хочешь тратить много времени и токенов, указываешь в каких конкретных местах, на каких фреймах эти изменения произошли.
И он в Components MD это записывает, чтобы в следующий раз, когда ты попросишь его что-то собрать, он к нему обратился и нашел эти новые компоненты.
Еще раз отмечу, потому что это очень важно.
Дальше у нас этап брифа.
Он смотрит, какие вообще теоретически могут тебе понадобиться дополнительно компоненты, чтобы закрыть тот функционал, который основным выделен у тебя в варфреймах и в принципе в среде.
И предлагает тебе ряд того, что можно внести.
И плюс еще там варианты того, что пока вносить не обязательно.
Говорим ему, да, круто, забираем их.
И он переходит на следующий этап.
Он собирает MD описание, то есть анатомию этих компонентов, их вариации, состояние.
Прописывает, какие у них там должны быть отступы.
В общем, полностью комплексно их описывает.
После чего переносит уже с помощью UseFigma в наш канвас в Figma.
Создает эти самые компоненты.
Сразу можем указывать, на какой странице это делать.
Можно создать секцию, указать ссылкой эту секцию и попросить именно в ней это сделать.
Сейчас мы посмотрим, почему лучше делать так.
И после того, как все это дело он собрал, он записывает все эти данные в каталог, в компонент MD.
И после чего ожидает, что ты у него запросишь аудит.
Все ли классно перенеслось, все ли здорово работает.
Я убрал в директиве, чтобы этот шаг выполнялся автоматически.
Потому что иногда он просто не нужен, а тебе придется ждать, пока он этот аудит проводит.
И тут я бы хотел, наверное, сразу выделить одну черту тех, кто пользуется агентами.
Тех, кто открывает для себя его возможности.
Все через это проходят.
Часто, ребята, кажется, что нужно давить его до талого, чтобы он тебя довел до результата, который ты там себе визуализировал.
Но дело в том, что не всегда это быстрее.
И таким образом ты проводишь просто часы за агентом по времени столько же, сколько ты бы это делал все вручную.
Смысла в такой работе нет.
Нужно помнить, что что-то все-таки удобнее и проще сделать руками.
Как, например, с тем, что мы смотрели.
Как, например, то, что мы видели в прошлом уроке, когда он высоту там неправильно поставил.
Выбрать этот хак проблем нет.
Можно его докапывать.
Нет, везде поставь хак.
Почему это не так и так далее.
Просто ждать время, наполнять контекст ненужным мусором.
И в итоге получить то, что ты мог сделать руками за 5 секунд.
То же самое касается даже отдельных инструментов.
Мне буквально доходило до того, что мне нужна какая-то программа, какой-то софт, который, не знаю, PDF-ки объединит все в одном месте.
Или из текста эти PDF-ки соберет.
Я просто начинал его заставлять собирать полноценное приложение, которым можно пользоваться.
Хотя, на самом деле, есть уже огромное количество решений для этого в интернете.
Но просто ты настолько в эти процессы погружаешься, что начинаешь требовать от агента все.
Поэтому не забываем, что для некоторых задач уже есть готовые решения.
Что некоторые задачи удобнее выполнить руками.
Это будет быстрее, чем каждый раз душить агента.
Итак, что от этой директивы, от этого процесса в целом ожидать.
Одиночные компоненты с прозрачной анатомией.
Там, тул-типы, тосты, бред-крамп, пагинации, какие-то кнопки, где 2-3-4 слоя, понятная семантика, мало вариантов.
Каркас собирается в таких случаях надежно, с первого прогона и занимает совсем мало времени.
А какие-то правки руками делаются за пару секунд.
Там, где у нас наборы со сложной матрицей, со сложной структурой, например, какие-нибудь таблицы, целые организмы уже собранные из атомов.
То тут, да, каркас выполняется на 70% и 30% доводки тебе придется делать.
Но на самом деле, постоянно выходит обновление Клода, он становится умнее, да и, в принципе, зачастую превосходит ожидания.
Но к этому результату стоит быть готовым, что 70% он соберет, а остальные 30% тебе придется уже довести руками.
Но, тем не менее, это тоже дело, я не знаю, 15 минут.
Я думаю, не проблема, если он собрал тебе огромное количество экранов, потратить 15 минут просто на то, чтобы их довести руками.
Это все, конечно, дольше.
И также нужно быть готовым, когда ты собираешь варианты компонентов, они могут начинать плыть, если их уже много.
То есть, если у тебя 2-3 варианта компонента, как зашито в директиве, то, скорее всего, все будет супер.
Если их там становится 7 и более, и они прям сильно разные, они просто цвет меняют, то здесь агент может уже начинать плыть.
Как ты можешь модифицировать эту директиву и ее менять в зависимости от своего проекта и каких-то своих ожиданий?
В нее изначально зашит список базовых элементов.
Он сравнивает этот список с тем, что тебе может пригодиться и создает уже какие-то более конкретизированные их варианты.
Соответственно, этот список ты можешь править самостоятельно, если что-то конкретное хочешь туда добавить.
Также можешь добавить, например, чтобы спейсинг токены явно были указаны для каждого слоя.
Все отступы, все отступы между элементами, паддинги, также внутренние отступы вертикальные, горизонтальные.
Если хочешь, чтобы они тоже задавались через токены, можешь это здесь явно указать.
Также предусмотрен быстрый прогон, то есть ты можешь написать команду skip audit, и он пропустит этап аудита, сразу быстренько создаст тебе все эти компоненты.
А остальное потом правишь руками.
Также можно вызывать по одному элементу, например, grow UI kit one tool tip, то есть что-то одно создать.
И можно указать, чтобы он делал остановку между фазами.
То есть после MD я хочу обсудить с командой, то есть указать, например, точки остановки, где ты хочешь прерваться, чтобы там с командой, например, обсудить вот эту структуру, которую он предлагает.
Ну и сами точечные правки конкретных элементов уже лучше делать вручную.
В Figma это будет намного быстрее, удобнее.
Просто не забываем его предупредить о том, что ты что-то поменял.
Так, давай посмотрим, что он собрал мне.
Ну, здесь видим сразу, что он не очень удачно все это дело расположил.
Я ему явно указал, что нужно работать на страничке компоненты, но он не догадался, что не нужно перекрывать то, что уже есть этими компонентами.
Ну, это на самом деле мелочи, это все можно поправить.
Что у нас здесь есть?
Во-первых, таблица.
Таблица в двух вариациях.
Компактная и по дефолту.
Это неплохая база, да, он здесь проставил все скругления, все стили.
Все это дело можно уже дальше поправить.
Тут, например, сумма типа у нас слипается, потому что по ширине он решил сделать узким этот блок.
Ну, в общем, это все можно доработать и много времени на это не уйдет.
Например, вот выберем эти наши ряды, расширим их.
Этап суммы ячейку мы сделаем побольше, например, 200 пикселей.
Даже можно не 200, а, к примеру, 100.
Следующий этап тоже можно расширить до 180, например, то есть до 200.
И вот этот этап также поставим здесь, пускай 110.
Все, у нас уже аккуратная таблица.
Здесь также можно поставить хак и создавать в ней новые строки.
Все это дело работает.
Тут у нас аккуратное скругление.
Все, с этим уже можно работать.
Как бы, по сути, компонент создан вручную.
Создавать его было бы значительно дольше.
Плюс тут у нас все привязано токенами, привязано текстовыми стилями.
В общем, заглядение.
Ну и точно так же с его второй вариацией.
Все это дело недолго доработать.
Также здесь у нас есть табы.
Он, как обычно, обрезал высоту, поэтому ставим хак.
Часто у него такое бывает.
Табы, как бы, ничего тут сложного нет.
Два варианта этих табов.
Можно двигаться дальше.
Тут ничего интересного.
Дальше.
Тул типы.
Опять та же проблема.
Хак.
Подсказка.
На самом деле он ее собрал довольно своеобразно, но пускай, допустим.
Дальше у нас дропдаун.
Также через хак это дело обнимем.
Тут тоже поставим хак.
Тут у нас все аккуратно с вариациями того, как выглядят кнопки в обычном состоянии, в ховер состоянии.
И кнопку удалить, она, да, будет отличаться.
Также у нас появился компонент select.
Открывается дропдаун.
У нас тут список вариантов.
Это все также тут иконочками можно дополнить.
Можно дать эту задачу агенту.
Просто нужно сразу сет иконок сюда закинуть.
Тоже мы это дело откладываем.
Идем дальше.
Тост.
Тут он совсем все сильно сжал.
Нужно у этих элементов поставить, наверное, хак, либо фиксированную какую-то высоту.
Сам тост тоже мы через хак.
Это, судя по всему, какие-то уведомления, что у нас меняется.
Также тут под иконку предусмотрено место.
Но это все можно будет в дальнейшем дополнить.
Хлебные крошки.
Опять фиксируем высоту.
У нас тут две вариации.
Активная страница и неактивная предыдущая.
Здесь он также сразу DemoPath собрал.
Как это будет выглядеть уже на готовом компоненте на странице.
Погенация точно так же он собрал для кнопки активное состояние и дефолтное.
И тоже сюда сделал демо.
Вот таким образом мы расширили нашу базовую библиотеку компонентов.
Вот таким образом мы расширили нашу библиотеку базовых компонентов с учетом уже нашей специфики,
как минимум в плейсхолдерах.
Также у меня табличный вид, сложная структура.
Это все под эти требования подходит.
Давайте еще на всякий случай покажу, как это выглядит здесь.
Точно так же просто закинул ему директиву, сказал выполняй.
И прервал его.
Решил сразу ему сообщить о том, что то, что он создавал в предыдущем уроке,
это отдельные секции на странице Foundations.
Я это изменил.
Я создал новые страницы, разделил компоненты и Foundations.
И он должен это учитывать, когда будет размещать эти компоненты.
Ну, что он в принципе и сделал.
Да, он это учел.
После чего он создал эти компоненты и в Components MD обновление записал.
Записал то, что он туда добавил.
Вот здесь как раз выделяется.
В самом верху этот текст добавился.
Также, как обычно, сделал скриншот, убедился, что все у нас есть, все добавлено.
И выдал summary по тому, какую работу он провел.
Добавился у нас, например, такой элемент, как Dropdown.
Тут он это описал.
Тип это ComponentsAid.
Какие у него есть состояния.
Какое у него Node.id.
И его назначение.
Контекстное меню, кебаб-триггер, панель опций.
То есть какое-то краткое описание, чтобы агент ориентировался.
На этом все.
После того, как мы всю эту работу выполнили,
если есть большое желание, можно добавить еще один вызов.
В сфере компоненты по UI-киту со стартовыми и с Foundation.
Но я сейчас открыл, посмотрел.
Везде все было проставлено.
За исключением каких-то моментов с высотой блоков.
Поэтому я необходимости здесь никакой не вижу.
Если ты видишь, что он что-то собрал не так,
что у тебя есть расхождение с твоей дизайн-системой,
то можешь запустить вот этот аудит.
И он посмотрит, где что совпадает, где нет.
И в дальнейшем уже он тебе выдаст краткую сводку,
укажет на ошибки.
И ты можешь уже либо сам их поправить,
либо попросить это сделать его.
Ну, самому какие-то мелочи поправить будет быстрее.
В домашнем задании заставляем нашего агента прогнать директиву Grow UI-кит,
чтобы он оценил, что тебе действительно нужно.
Не забываем указывать это.
Получаем ряд компонентов, правим их руками,
либо отправляем на аудит, заставляем его это сделать.
И получаем какой-то результат.
Точно так же мы все это дело создаем новые компоненты
на уже существующей у тебя странице.
Для удобства при проверке можешь просто выделить,
какие компоненты добавились именно в этой итерации.
Но я думаю, в принципе, по их сложности будет так понятно.
Для сдачи домашнего задания присылаем ссылку на Figma файл
и не лишним будет скриншот.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
Увидимся в следующих уроках.